in this video you're going to learn the
algebraic tests for Symmetry and we're
going to go through five examples
together so how do you test an equation
to see if the graph is going to be
symmetric about the x axis or the Y AIS
or the origin that's what we're going to
be talking about in this video and we've
got some little rules here that you
might want to make a note of but I want
to show you why they work take for
example a point like this point here 3
comma 1 if I reflect this over the xaxis
it's like folding over that xaxis it's
the mirror image you can see that this
point would end up right here at
31 so what happened well when reflected
over the x-axis the y coordinate change
sign to the opposite so you can see here
when we're testing for uh x-axis
symmetry we replace y with negative Y
and if we get the original equation back
when we simplify then that tells us it's
symmetric about the xaxis now say you
take this 31 and you reflect it over the
Y AIS that would put you right over here
and notice that this point is
-31 so what happened here when you
reflect over the Y AIS it's actually the
x coordinate that's changing signs and
so when you test for y axis symmetry you
replace x with negative X in your
equation and when you simplify if you
get that original equation back it tells
you that it has y-axis Symmetry and then
if you were to take this point here 31
and rotate it
180° okay about the origin like you're
turning about this point you would end
up over here at
-31 so what happened there well you can
see the x is the opposite sign and the Y
is the opposite sign and so what you do
in your equation is replace x with
negative X and Y with negative Y and if
you get that original equation back when
you simplify then it tells you that it
has origin Symmetry and keep in mind
that it could have X Y An Origin all of
them or maybe just two of the different
types of symmetry or just one one or
maybe that doesn't have any symmetry at
all so that's what we're going to look
at in these five examples starting with
example number one so let's test for
xaxis symmetry first so we're going to
replace y with negative y so wherever I
see y I'm just going to put in a
negative y I usually like to put it in
parentheses just to treat it like a
group and then when I simplify a
negative times a negative is just going
to give us a
positive and when I look at this
equation is it the same as the or orinal
equation no it's not you can see this is
negative y this is positive y so that
tells me that it doesn't have x-axis
symmetry meaning if I fold it over the
x-axis it's not going to match with
itself okay so let's look at y-axis
symmetry now let's replace uh x with
negative X so if we do that in this
original equation replacing x with
negative
X and simplifying when you have a
negative to an even power that's a
negative time a negative time a negative
time a negative you're going to get a
positive x to the
4th and when I look at this equation you
can see it does match the original so
that tells me that okay yes it does have
y- axis Symmetry and then let's test for
the origin we're going to replace x with
negative X and Y with negative y let's
see what happens there so we've
gotx to the
4th y with negative
Y and again you can see a negative to an
even power gives us a positive a
negative * a negative is a positive and
you can see that this does not match the
original so it does not have origin
Symmetry and so in this case it looks
like we just had Y axis symmetry that
was it now you might be saying Mario
what do you mean x-axis symmetry y- axis
symmetry origin symmetry let's look at
some examples really quick so Y axis
symmetry might look something like this
for example see if I fold it over the y-
AIS see how it matches to itself uh
x-axis symmetry might look look
something like this or if I fold it this
way over the x- axxis it matches to
itself origin symmetry might look
something like
this where if I hold my finger right at
the origin and I turn this 180 degrees
like the paper halfway it will match to
itself and so that's what we're talking
about when we talk about symmetry so
let's look at example number two now
what do you think on this one does it
have xaxis y AIS origin it could have
more than one it could have none right
let's start in order so let's replace
one y with Y so that's going to be
2x notice the
parentheses and I can see a negative
squared is going to be a
positive so yeah it looks like that
matches the original so this does have
x-axis symmetry okay that's interesting
let's check y- axis now so we're
replacing x with negative
X okay we've got a positive times a
negative time a positive that's going to
be a -2X
y^2 and does that look like the original
no so it doesn't have y- axis Symmetry
and then how about for origin let's
replace both X and Y with the opposite
sign and simplify so here we have a
negative squ which is a positive y^ 2
times this negative would be a negative
so this is coming out to -2X
y^2 which does not match the original so
it doesn't have origin symmetry so in
this case it looks like we just had the
x-axis symmetry so let's write that down
again keep in mind you can have one of
these two of these three of these or
none of them let's look at a couple more
examples okay see if you can pause a
video and do number three four and five
on your own to test yourself but if I
was going to do number three I'm going
to follow the same pattern I'm going to
start with the x-axis symmetry I'm going
to replace y with negative y so if we do
that let's see what we get we've got uh
x = 2 * - y over y^ 2 - 1 and I'm going
to simplify this a little bit more so
this would become x = -2 y over y *
ative Y is a positive y^2 minus 1 now
does this match the original almost
except for we have this negative here so
I would say does not have X AIS symmetry
Let's test for y-axis symmetry so y-axis
symmetry replacing x with X so you can
almost basically see here if I replace
this with neax it's not going to match
the other side so we know that it
doesn't have y AIS Symmetry and then
let's test for origin we're going to
replace x with negative X and Y with
negative y so we're placing both
variables with the opposite sign and we
simplify here what's interesting is we
get a -2 y in the numerator a negative y
* a negative Y is a positive y^2 - 1 in
the denominator and at first glance you
might say well Mario this doesn't look
like the left side and the right side
match it's different from the original
but what you can do is you can multiply
the left side and the right side by
negative 1 now negative 1 is like
negative 1 over positive 1 so if I
multiply both sides by negative 1 over
positive 1 this is going to give us a
positive
X this is going to give us a positive2 y
and the denominator 1 * anything is
itself sometimes students mistakenly
multiply the denominator by negative 1
and the numerator well negative 1 divid
NE 1 is a positive one so you just want
to multiply the numerator by negative 1
and you can see that this does match the
original so in this case this one only
had origin symmetry where we can rotate
at 180 degrees about the origin okay so
what do you think for number four and
number five what did you get for for
these ones now you might be saying at
this point Mario can I just look at the
exponent like if I see the Y the
exponent is even and I know that if I
put in a negative it's going to going to
be a positive and yeah as you do these
more and more you're going to basically
be able to look at you're going to be
able to say oh yeah I can see it's got
this type of symmetry or that type of
symmetry but you might on a quiz or a
test have to demonstrate this for your
teacher that show that you understand it
that you're like it's kind of like a
proof so let's test for x-axis symmetry
let's replace y with negative y so this
would be like negative y going in for y
a negative to an even power is positive
see this one I probably could have just
done just by looking at it and I can see
that oh yeah this does have x-axis
symmetry so I'll just put a little check
xaxis symmetry now we're going to check
for y- axis by replacing x with negative
X you can probably see that just by
replacing this with a Negative X that's
going to give us a - 3x it's not going
to match the original right okay so it
doesn't have the uh the y- axis Symmetry
and then how about for the origin if we
replace x with Nega
X and Y with negative
y let's see this gives gives us positive
y 4th we still have this negative here
in front this gives us a -
3x and when you look at this you can see
it doesn't match the original you might
be tempted to say well Mario what about
that last example where you multiplied
by negative one we could multiply the
left and right sides by negative one
this would give us 3x + y 4 = -1 still
doesn't match the original so this
doesn't have any origin symmetry so in
this case it looks like it's just the
x-axis
Symmetry and last example we'll see if
you can do this one 8x^2 y^2 - 2 = 0 and
while you're doing that I wanted to let
you know about my two video courses that
I have for sale my algebra 1 and my
algebra 2 video course for sale so if
you like the way that I explain things
and you're thinking to yourself you know
Mara I wish you were my teacher can't
you just come here and teach my math
class these courses are are very much
like that where I take you step by step
through a typical Algebra 1 course and a
typical Algebra 2 course with uh the
theory and the uh explanations and
example problems and some opportunities
for you to even practice on your own and
then we go through those problems as
well so those courses are really helpful
links in the description below and if
you just want to support you know the
videos I'm putting up here on my Mario
math tutoring YouTube channel I uh
encourage you to join and become a
channel member so for a few dollars a
month you can support the channel and I
see all of the uh YouTube handles or the
the channel names that come through and
so I really appreciate the support of my
channel CH members so consider doing
that what did you get for number five
did you get X AIS y AIS origin two of
them three of them one of them none of
them let's go through them so for x-axis
we replace y with negative Y and let's
just talk through this so if I put a
negative Y in here a negative y^2 that's
going to be positive y^2 you can see
you're going to get the original back so
this does have x-axis symmetry let's put
a check there if we replace with y- axis
symmetry replace x with negative X and
again you can see if I just replace this
with negative x negative x^2 is positive
x^2 I'm getting back the original so it
does look like it has Y axis symmetry
origin I make these both negative let's
maybe demonstrate that one let's write
that out so replacing x with negative X
Y with negative y a negative squar is a
positive negative squar is a positive
and you can see we're getting the
original equation back so that tells us
it has origin symmetry so in this case
it had all three and so great job you
got it so if you want to see more
examples you want to test yourself you
want to practice more or just want some
more explanation follow me over to a
previous video that I did on the same
topic talking about algebraic tests for
symmetry I'll see you over in that video